i'm scarlet foo this is bloomberg quick
take
a powerful storm that ripped across the
midwest and great plains with hurricane
force winds killed at least five people
the powerful system spawned tornadoes
toppling trees and leaving nearly 500
000 homes and businesses without power
winds gusted to 90 miles per hour with
temperatures unseasonably warm the
national weather service says 21
tornadoes were reported with at least 19
outbreaks of hail some of which reached
the size of a softball and the system
came on the heels of devastating
tornadoes last weekend that cut a path
through kentucky and of course
neighboring states as well this killed
more than 85 people american red cross
spokesperson kelly edwards joins us
joining us now from kentucky for an
update callie thank you for being here
and glad to see that you're okay i know
you've been on the ground give us a
sense of the situation what are you
seeing and how bad is it
so for the past couple of days i've been
in the city of mayfield kentucky
surveying the damage and talking with um
residents and it is it is something that
i have never seen before
in 10 years of serving with the american
red cross the devastation it just
looks
so immense compared to some of the other
tornado responses i have served on
but what is clear is that the residents
and the community are coming together to
find ways to help this these communities
recover
that is certainly good to hear um
despite all the damage one thing that
strikes me kelly is that we're getting
better at predicting when and where
tornadoes specifically do strike yet the
damage they incur when they strike is
pretty crippling why is that why haven't
we gotten better at that part of it
well i'm not a client a meteorologist so
i can't speak to weather
specifically like that but one of the
things that we do know with the red
cross is that these types of disasters
continue to happen they happen more
often and one of the things that the red
cross as we try to be prepared and try
to prepare communities we encourage
individuals to also be prepared to know
the signs of danger and heed those
warnings
with tornadoes you often only get a
couple of seconds or minutes to respond
so being able to have those emergency
alerts in your community or from your
red cross emergency app can help you
take cover
i spoke with one resident that um had
heard the
the tornado alert and she immediately
ran into her bathroom and took shelter
in her bathtub and when she recovered
when her neighbors came to check on her
she found that her home was in pieces
and so
the time that people take to take those
steps to take cover can make a
difference and save lives and i know
that you're in kentucky where 110 people
were working in a candle factory when a
tornado came through and of course 90
were found in the rubble of that factory
after the fact
that example just makes me wonder to
what extent the victims that you've
heard of tend to be coming from
individuals like the one you mentioned
who are in their houses at the time or
is a lot of it people who were actually
at work and their employers kept them
there
so i can't speak to companies and the
employee situations like that
what i can speak to is that i've spoken
with residents and business community
members that had businesses in downtown
mayfield and they saw that destruction
and they saw their businesses basically
be imploded by this disaster
and so it's been very devastating for
them but they also
are very thankful to be alive they're
thankful for the partners and community
members coming together to help them
start taking those steps towards
recovery
so americans seeing these pictures are
obviously devastated by by what what the
damage that has been done to to all
these people who were in the wrong place
at the wrong time really
can you give us a sense of the donations
that have come in uh to help people in
the region
all right what does the trajectory of
that look like and is it earmarked for
this area this region these storms
specifically
thank you for asking that because i know
people are looking at these images and
wondering how they can help and people
are stepping up and helping to make
financial donations to the red cross and
other partners that are responding in
these disasters financial funds help us
get resources to people and the who need
it and who need it in place and where
it's needed most the most quickly
also people can also make blood
donations in their community to help us
we're within we're in a national blood
shortage at this time we've had the
lowest blood supply in in a decade and
so donating blood is a great way in a
free way that individuals can commute
contribute and help i wonder how kovid
comes into play with this is that one
element that's made it difficult to get
the blood donations needed to help the
survivors in the area
absolutely now one of the things i will
say the red cross
and as far as related to the tornadoes
the red cross provided over 200 units of
blood
for
hospitals in this area to help with the
disaster response
red cross as a national blood bank we're
able to get blood products where they're
needed most
one of the keys is that
people that donate today and tomorrow
help make sure blood is on the shelves
when these emergencies happen and
hospital patients need it when they get
it when they need it most
can you kelly give us a sense of where
we are in the disaster relief effort
because i know there tends to be stages
in in how this rolls out where are we in
this are we early on uh in the early
innings middle innings
we are we are still early on in this
response i can tell you on wednesday
night hundreds of people were still
spending the night in 10 um cross and
community partner shelters across the
states
the red cross we we have provided over
seven or over 7 000 meals and snacks at
this point
even like a day like today where we're
experiencing some severe weather in
kentucky our volunteers and our partners
are still sheltering feeding helping to
provide that
those resources and comfort
i will also say that our team our
volunteers are also reaching out to the
people that have been affected by these
by these storms and that have lost loved
ones the red cross has disaster
health services mental health and
spiritual care volunteers that are
helping to make touch with these
families and help provide
to their emotional needs after going
through such a devastating event
kelly final question for you when you
look ahead and kind of take a step back
here what are you most concerned about
moving forward is it the kind of
diminishing effect of relief a few
months out from events like this is it
the lack of blood donations that we're
seeing what are you most worried about
so what i would say when these disasters
happen i'm from north carolina i've seen
many tornadoes and many hurricane
disasters in my 10 years in the red
cross
these disasters take time and long after
the
cameras turn away from the disaster
there is still relief efforts that need
are happening in that area this is going
to be a long recovery there's going to
be many partners many people involved in
the recovery of for these communities
and so
it's a busy time everyone is also
focused on their holiday plans and
season but think about these families
and how you can possibly help through a
financial donation or blood donation and
if you're not able to do those
encourage your concur be encouraged to
join us as a volunteer to help in your
community as well
really really helpful thank you callie
edwards spokesperson for the american
red cross joining us from kentucky
where of course the state has suffered
so many recent natural
disasters
cali thank you so much